- What is quantum mechanics?
- Quantum mechanics is
the paradigm of physics
that came into being in the
early part of the 20th century
that replaced classical mechanics.
And it replaced classical
mechanics in a weird way
that we're still coming to terms with.
So in classic mechanics,
you have an object,
it has a location, it has a velocity,
and if you know the location and velocity
of everything in the world,
you can say what everything's going to do.
Quantum mechanics has an aspect of it
that is kind of on the same line,
so there's something
called the quantum state,
or the wave function,
and there's an equation
governing what the quantum state does.
So it's very much like
classical mechanics.
The wave function is different,
it's sort of a wave, it's a vector,
in a huge dimensional vector space,
rather than a position or velocity,
but okay, that's a detail.
And the equation is, the
Schrodinger Equation,
not Newton's law, is, but
okay, again, a detail.
Where quantum mechanics really
becomes weird and different
is that there's a whole
nother set of rules
in our textbook formulation
of quantum mechanics,
in addition to saying that
there's a quantum state
and it evolves in time.
And all these new rules have to do with
what happens when you look at this system,
when you observe it, when you measure it.
In classical mechanics, there
were no rules about observing.
You just look at it, and
you see what's going on,
that was it, right?
In quantum mechanics, the way we teach it,
there's something profoundly fundamental
about the act of
measurement or observation,
and the system dramatically
changes its state.
Even though it has a wave function,
like the electron and an atom
is not orbiting in a circle,
it's sort of spread out in a cloud.
When you look at it, you
don't see that cloud.
When you look at it,
it looks like a particle with a location.
So it dramatically changes
its state right away.
And the affects of that
change can be instantly seen
in what the electron does next.
So that's the, again,
we need to be careful
because we don't agree on
what quantum mechanics says,
that's why I need to say,
like, in the textbook views,
et cetera, right, but
in the textbook view,
quantum mechanics, unlike
any other theory of physics,
places, gives a fundamental
role to the act of measurement.